j'accueille eugène saccomano
bonsoir aux jeunes bonsoir pays alors
vous savez ce soir nous avons avec nous
le père pedro qui est un être
exceptionnel
ah si vraiment ce sera l'un des vrais
man made répète donc voilà et le père
pedro
m voilà un fan de foot n'est vraiment
chercher le plus grand commentateur
sportif de france
à oui c'est le roi c'est vrai vous avez
cité bout d'un moment vous ai fait
beaucoup de foot vous avez mais nous
nous avions une argentine aussi des ce
qui transmettait les football y aller le
couteau
muñoz il vous fait plaider devant
démarrer mon innocence
mais hier c'est le meilleur des
meilleurs extraits voilà je l'avais
rencontré en 1977 lors de la petite
tournée de l'équipe de france en
argentine au brésil
et c'est vrai que ça extraordinaire
l'écouté ces menaces à une vitesse
éclair
oui mais c'est le propre aussi
jean-françois de la langue espagnole qui
permet ça une rapidité sanguinaire dans
l'évolution que nous n'avons pas et vous
ne savez pas dire non plus gaulle
si tu arrives en sortir et de crier ça
le matin tous les matins on lui fait une
émission isabelle roullot match commencé
le grand ses gardes ont fait le match
certains matches on se demande pourquoi
leur père même temps un ouais oui
j'aimerais les bons comme les mauvais
ici et sur rtl
voilà moi je suis un grand fan de votre
émission sur lci là je suis quelqu'un
train autour de vous mais ils sont
sympathiques comme ça ça écorche au
moins c'est bien mais non c'est une
émission très sympathique même quand on
n'est pas trop fan de foot c'est marrant
de voir very série alors vous publiez
jeunes c'est comme un hochet plan un
livre qui s'appelle jeu refait le match
et là c'est le match de votre vie alors
on découvre qu'à l'origine de votre
vocation c'est un jour au lycée de nîmes
pendant un chahut vous vous mettez à
imiter les grands reporter sportif de
l'époque et l'occasion comment ça se
passe je sais tout ça se passe que
j'avais un professeur qui était de maths
qui était totalement sourd mais ce que
j'appelle totalement sourd et on allait
le voir généralement si bien qu'on
pouvait le voir d'ailleurs le bouquin de
commence là dessus je sais que je peux
aller baiser votre femme évidemment il y
en avait un autre qui était déjà aux
toilettes et il nous répondait attendez
que votre camarade
albert est donc
il avait il était saoul et on pouvait
s'exprimer
soc pendant les compos les contrôler
tout ça où il fallait garder la main
devant la bouche parce qu'ils lisent
elle est sur les lèvres
mais sinon ça va c'était des matchs de
foot en direct c'est lé gala de variétés
tout quoi et là vous découvrez en fait
que c'est votre vocation cette histoire
de commentaires sportifs un jour vous
découvrez une affiche au lycée le
concours du meilleur radio reporter
sportif juniors de france
vous remportez les éliminatoires à nîmes
et vous vous retrouvez invité en 52 se
dire en 52 j'étais jeune à éviter aux
jeux olympiques d'helsinki
j'avais 15 ans quoi ouais c'est ça quand
même alors sur le bateau en live en a
épaté ou découvrit en fait que vous
découvrez aussi c'est une crise de
vocation vous découvrez que vous êtes
amateurs vous avez bien regardé un vous
n'avez jamais regardé avant l'heure il
s'est brûlé
suivant les immats 5 australienne et il
s'est brûlé par une femme mariée d'une
quarantaine d'années avec je prends pour
une vieille way
qu'est-ce que celle ci donnera côté a
battu peu l'a tellement fait le travail
quoi et depuis ce jour là vous avez un
certain mépris un certain dédain pour la
copulation ordinaire faut le dire ont
dit non quand le chat ouais je présente
mon gré
la sq est non mais c'est vrai que
j'aimais bien
j'ai toujours été un mater en master de
la vie amateurs du sexe football amateur
du football et on recommence et oui
avant de le commenter pour regarder le
tout bien sûr bien sûr c'est un peu
comme le sexe voilà un jeune artiste
c'est un seul atteint le jeune tu sais
qu'il aimerait jeunesse richard a
pardonné et ma jeunesse
d'ailleurs quand vous parlez quand vous
parlez de votre amour des corridas de la
feria de nîmes en fait ce que vous dites
dans le bouquin c'est surtout les
vilenies cad est euphorique dans les
jardins de nîmes que c'est ça qui vous
intéressent au moment de la feria vous
dans les jambes puisque les taureaux à
non non non c'était quand même fasciné
par les toreros de l'époque qui était
luis miguel dominguin prin et et antonio
ordonez et puis il y avait toute une
clique de gens qui met blue hissé à
l'époque c'était hemingway hama garner
qui venait dans cette wii qui venait
dans l'hôtel imperator rendez vous sur
les plaques d'ailleurs à la chambre de
lagardère est là la chambière buzz lucia
bosé toi là bas au milieu et la mère de
la gdt ailleurs signé alors voilà je
vous êtes engagés au journal le
provençal un votre avenir est tout tracé
derrière vous le comprenez assez assez
rapidement vous laissez tomber vos
velléités de devenir footballeur parce
que vous avez oui mais leurs débuts il
écrivait que ses pieds comme un vrai ce
n'est qu'après alors ensuite vous
racontez votre carrière en provençal
correspondant d'europe1 numéro un à
marseille
el hadj écrivez votre premier bouquin
gènes qui s'appelle bandits à marseille
qui deviendra borsalino voilà ce gène
qui a écrit borsellino le film avec
belmondo et de long mise en scène par
jacques deray alors quand même deux
conséquences négatives à cette histoire
la première si vous n'avez pas touché un
rond ça c'est pas de la faute de jacques
deray venons et hommes les personnes pas
réussi vous aviez 0,50 pour cent sur les
terrains de longues expliqué pas d'alain
delon mais sa société de production mais
c'était pas lui c'était bon il y avait
georges bomy avait toute une équipe qui
gérait le truc qui avait acheté les
droits à juillard et il est vrai que la
paramount qui détient les droits
actuellement ne verse pas un seul
centime c'est à dire que moi j'ai touché
le premier à valloire rien du tout c'est
à dire
soixante mille fois en / de 30 mille
francs sans doute oui c'est ça avec
l'éditeur et depuis rien contre a tiré
alors oui il faut lire les contrats mais
c'était dans le contrat et payer un
excellent film qui a fait le tour du
monde et qui a connu un succès énorme au
japon partout quoi
le deuxième type c'est qu'il ya une
suite non le deuxième trucs négatifs
c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est que
c'est des menaces de mort du milieu
enfin c'est ce que vous croyez en tous
les cas à l'époque
et puis ça a été terrible pour vous
parce que vous avez pris ça très au
sérieux
vous avez fait des criques commencé dans
les crises d'asthme dépression nerveuse
envies de suicide enfin c'était c'est
chaud c'était sérieux
j'ai eu très peur et je n'ai su que bien
plus tard peut-être dix quinze ans plus
tard que c'était une énorme farce
macabre lancer enfin papa par un
[ __ ]
on peut le dire bon personam il est mort
ma faim tout de même à qui veut les r
c'est un jaloux il a peut-être connu
dans le temps jean paul claude innocent
si on faisait les procès il avait une
bonne plume d'ailleurs symbole jambon
journaliste donc le lait cru pendant
qu'en même temps ces dragages lait cru
pendant samad démoralisé ça m'a foutu en
l'air pendant combien vraiment en l'air
pendant quatre cinq ans je laisse u10
rose an après 1
mais c'est vrai que quand je suis arrivé
à paris en 70 j'étais encore très marqué
par ce truc là quoi ouais je me
retournais dans la rue enfin jeu c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles vous
êtes venu à paris d'ailleurs dirigé le
service des sports d'europe voilà oui
alors vous raconter aussi eugène
saccomano votre amour de céline louis
ferdinand céline et vous avez écrit un
bouquin real s'appelle concours 32 c'est
vrai consacré aux types qu'il a ux avait
le masque line en fait c'est pas le
voyage au bout de la nuit qu'ils c'est à
dire que quand j'ai rencontré mazeline
parce qu'ils étaient encore vivants en
96 97
le pauvre mazeline qui avait 93 ans qui
était bien dans sa tête encore
physiquement il était un peu diminué je
lui dis parlez-moi de céline et là ça a
été terrible il me répond à vous aussi
c'est à dire que ce type là passé sa vie
à parler de son ex frère
on lui a fait on lui a demandé de
raconter tout sur céline et rien sur lui
le pauvre alors ils avaient
et à l'époque avant guerre une oeuvre
littéraire qui certes ne sait pas quand
ni son actionnaire le type il a le prix
goncourt en 32 c'est le moment de sa vie
et à chaque fois qu'on parle de 30 euros
10 32 c'est l'année où céline bourgault
alors qu'il l'a eu c'est un drame
terrible oui c'est un joueur formidable
les comme vous allez voir votre ami
tapis en prison voulu apporter des
livres de céline
oui parce que j'apprends comme ça chez
plus qu il me dit qu'il se lançait un
peu dans les bouquins de céline ça lui a
plu ben je crois que ça lui a plu iman
avait parlé après voilà enfin c'est un
livre très intéressant votre bouquin
c'est ses traits pagnolesque c'est tout
c'est écrit beaucoup de beaucoup de
verve
ça s'appelle jeu refait le match eugène
saccomano
eugène une question maintenant quand on
voit ce que font les bleus on peut dire
que la coupe du monde en 98 étaient
truquées non franchement non honnêtement
honnêtement gènes dont on a tendance à
n'était pas truqué mais il y avait une
règle a fait il y avait une mise en
place par aimé jacquet qui a bien
favorisé la victoire c'est que la mise
en place c'était au fait une équipe
défensive on ne prend pas de but ou très
peu non et on va gagner comme ça avec
des coups de génie des coups d'éclat
dylan et c'est comme ça qu'on a gagné
mais c'était pas du tout truqués vous
croyez qu'ils vont arriver à se
qualifier pour le prochain mondial les
bleus moi je crois qu'ils font est ce
qu'on appelle les barrages c'est à dire
qu'ils ne seront pas suffisamment bons
pour terminer en est
ils ont terminé second ils seront
obligés de faire des matchs
complémentaires pour se qualifier mais
je crois quand même qu'ils vont y
arriver jeudi peuvent pas faire quand
des îles peuvent pas faire des pubs des
émissions de télé à répétition des
livres qui s'écrivent pas eux mêmes et
les opérations de promotion et continuer
à vibrer à la balance à séoul s'est
prise en main assez incroyable là tu as
trop suivi père pedro n'est pas ouais
nous ré fait pour la france sur les
terres madagascar on regarde les matchs
des poules à face il ne convainc pas 1
cd on paie des millions ces personnes là
qu'il ne courait pas
et sort de la bouche du père pedro est
ce que vous voyez le jeune que zidane
doit revenir en équipe de france
non parce qu il a dit d'une manière
définitive qu'ils ne viendraient pas on
a essayé de lui faire dire on a un peu
truqueurs l'interview qu'il allait
revenir
alors il à dire arrêtez de me prendre
pour un imbécile j'ai dit une bonne fois
pour toutes que je ne venais pas je ne
reviendrai pas bon parce que il a il est
à un âge où il ya des choses très
fatigante en matière de football c'est
vrai les saints notamment où on est
éloigné pendant longtemps de sa famille
et puis physiquement aussi
il n'a plus des jambes de 20 ans 25 ans
il va revenir